continuez à vivre malgré tout surtout
pour les enfants c'est l'objectif de la
mairie de Kiev à travers cet arbre de
Noël érigé près de la cathédrale
Sainte-Sophie
nous avons eu beaucoup de débats
là-dessus et à la fin on s'est mis
d'accord pour fêter le Nouvel An et Noël
parce que pour les enfants c'est très
important nous voulions également
montrer aux Russes notre volonté de
gagner
un arbre aux couleurs jaune et bleu du
drapeau ukrainien décoré de colombes
blanches symboles de paix à son sommet
un trident d'or illuminé les armoiries
du pays plusieurs dizaines de personnes
ont bravé le froid glacial pour assister
à l'inauguration
j'ai des sentiments confus je ressens de
la douleur je ne suis pas du tout
d'humeur festive parce que ma famille
est acquieffe maintenant
même à ville d'origine dans la région de
louansk est occupée
même volonté de mettre un peu de beaux
moqueur à la gare centrale de Kiev ou
les enfants ont pu rencontrer
Saint-Nicolas avant qu'il ne prenne le
train pour aller distribuer quelques 30
000 cadeaux aux enfants de Kerson de
barmouth ou encore de carquive car qui
vous c'est le métro qui a été décoré
pour protéger la population
d'éventuelles frappes aériennes russes
c'est super j'aime beaucoup cela nous
fait du bien les enfants sont heureux
tout le monde prend des photos on a
l'impression d'être en vacances c'est
excellent
tous ne souhaitent qu'une chose que les
festivités puissent se dérouler l'an
prochain au sein de la ville la paix une
fois revenu